The SCP Foundation is an organization that polices
the abnormal in all its forms. Whether it’s a
multidimensional chaos god, a big scaly monster,
or a very effective coffee machine, the Foundation
takes a pointed interest in pretty much anything
outside the norm. So, you’re probably wondering:
What would they want with Mr. Smith, a man who
was about as normal and average as could be?
Mr. Smith was a 47-year-old, African American
construction worker with a wife and daughter.
He lived a modest but contented life
- he had a circle of close friends,
a happy family, and was well-liked among
his coworkers. But Mr. Smith had no idea
about the anomalous nightmare barreling
down the tracks towards him. Mr. Smith
wasn’t just about to have his life destroyed
by an anomaly - he was about to become one.
It seemed like a normal day at work on the
construction site when he received a phone call.
It was the police, informing him that his
wife and young daughter had been involved
in a terrible car accident. While
this is anyone’s worst nightmare,
it was only the start of the horrifying things
that were about to happen to poor, poor Mr. Smith.
That night, when Mr. Smith went to sleep,
he fell victim to a strange phenomenon:
He started to disappear. While it would be easy to
write off as the result of mental illness - like
a kind of stress-induced mental breakdown -
Mr. Smith wasn’t the only one who noticed.
Or rather, didn’t notice.
His coworkers would slowly begin to forget
details about him - even obvious things that
you could glean from simply looking
at a person, like clothes, height,
or skin color. It seemed that, little
by little, ever since his family died,
Mr. Smith was becoming an un-person. This led to
increasing levels of fear, paranoia, and distress,
as people whom he’d thought of as his closest
friends could barely recognize him anymore.
Thankfully, Mr. Smith wasn’t just going to slip
straight into non-existence without a fight.
He realized early on that his new
condition seemed to abide by certain rules.
The effects got worse in the night when he was
alone, but seemed to lessen somewhat during the
day when he was interacting with people.
It seemed that he disappeared just that
little bit more whenever he wasn’t being
interacted with - and perhaps he hadn’t
developed this condition upon the death of his
wife and child. Maybe he’d had it for a while,
but it was the constant presence of his
family that kept the effects from worsening.
But now that he’d properly identified the problem,
Mr. Smith could begin devising some solutions.
If nobody else was there to interact with him at
night, he’d keep his position in reality stable by
interacting with himself. Mr. Smith would repeat
his own name to himself regularly, reaffirming his
existence to himself. He’d often check his own
pulse to feel the rhythm of his heartbeat. He’d
write detailed descriptions of himself, either on
his own body or a surrounding surface. And in one
particular stroke of genius, he devised a method
of recording his own voice talking to himself,
and playing it back while he was
asleep to stave off reality decay.
During the day, while at work or
just existing socially in the world,
he’d do everything he could to constantly
interact with people. That way, they could
keep reaffirming his presence, and therefore,
continuing his existence. The symptoms of Mr.
Smith’s condition are somewhat similar to a rare
mental illness known as The Cotard Delusion,
in which a patient believes they
are dead, dying, or don’t even
exist. Except in Mr. Smith’s unfortunate
case, the Delusion was becoming a reality.
And this was a reality that Mr. Smith could
only hold off for so long. Little by little,
the coping mechanisms he’d built to manage
his new life began to collapse. People in
his inner circle truly began to forget him. His
company no longer recognized him as an employee.
To the people who barely knew him, he was little
more than a ghost. A kind of palpable absence.
This was the point when the SCP Foundation finally
got involved. They swooped in and apprehended Mr.
Smith, re-designating him as SCP-1467. It was
one of the rare occasions that the Foundation
didn’t need to apply any Amnestic treatment to
bystanders, because - due to the nature of Mr.
Smith’s anomalous activity - almost everyone who
knew him was already in the process of forgetting
him. When the Foundation interviewed a A man
that Mr. Smith referred to as a close friend,
he couldn’t even recall Mr. Smith’s basic
physical traits with any reliability.
Because of Mr. Smith’s condition, the
Foundation had real difficulty verifying
elements of his backstory. Mr. Smith told the
Foundation researchers everything about himself,
about his family and his life before,
but field agents were stumped whenever
they tried to follow up on the information.
First, there were the issues with the existence
and fate of his supposed wife and child.
No records were ever found of
either of these people existing,
and there was no existing documentation
to prove that Mr. Smith was ever married.
The Foundation also looked into the
deaths of Mrs. Smith and her child:
There were no records of a car crash in
the area that Mr. Smith directed them to.
But that’s not all. There
were also no death records,
nor any graves ever found. The construction
company that Mr. Smith claimed to work for
had no records of his employment. They
couldn’t find any of Mr. Smith’s supposed
extended family either. The only proof that
he had ever existed was his physical body,
locked in a Foundation humanoid containment
cell, and Mr. Smith’s own words. If you think
this sounds like a living nightmare, then
Mr. Smith would wholeheartedly agree with
you. The effects of his anomalous nature
traumatized Mr. Smith - he was diagnosed
by Foundation therapists as suffering from Bipolar
Depression, as well as chronic sleep deprivation.
Though if you disappeared a
little more every time you slept,
you’d probably lose a lot of sleep, too.
The unpredictable nature of Mr. Smith’s
anomalous traits could have equally
unpredictable effects on the nature of his
containment, so he was classified as Euclid.
Mr. Smith is one of the few anomalies that
is referred to by his real name - at least
to his face. When referred to as SCP-1467,
Mr. Smith enters a state of rage and panic,
and this mistake has caused several
injuries for Foundation personnel
during attempts to restrain him after
using his SCP number around him.
Mr. Smith is contained in a foam-padded
cell to prevent self-destructive behavior,
along with three audio recording devices,
though these were installed at his own request,
in order to continue his habit of recording his
own voice to play back to himself while asleep.
This served the dual purpose of not
only mitigating his fading from reality,
but also keeping him calm and docile during
containment, and these devices are kept in
good working order in order to avoid creating
hostility between Mr. Smith and Foundation staff.
While it may seem that the anomalous
effects of Mr. Smith purely serve to
create a personal hell for him and him
alone, the Foundation wasn’t so sure.
The fact no records could be found of his wife,
daughter, or extended family was concerning.
It raised one frightening question: Are the
effects of Mr. Smith’s condition contagious?
If so, he could be putting a
lot of people in grave danger.
Foundation Scientists, headed by Senior
Researcher Dr. Thorn, devised a series
of experiments to better understand Mr. Smith’s
mysterious condition. There were 22 Experiments
in total, but things began to get interesting
at around Experiment 16. For this experiment,
Mr. Smith was forcibly restrained, and brought
into a research chamber with Research assistants
Reiner and Dieter. They were told to simply
observe Mr. Smith without interacting with him,
and record what happened in the
process while Dr. Thorn supervised.
At 10 minutes and twelve seconds, the researchers
were unable to recognize the subject as Mr. Smith.
At 14 minutes and 32 seconds, they were
unable to recognize the clothes of Mr. Smith.
Less than ten minutes later, they were unable
to identify his race. Five minutes after that,
they couldn’t identify what
Mr. Smith was currently doing.
Ten minutes later, they couldn’t even
identify how Mr. Smith was sitting.
At almost 40 minutes, the research assistants
weren’t able to identify anything of Mr. Smith,
save for the fact that there was some
kind of humanoid creature in the room.
At this point, Research Assistant Dieter started
a recording, instructing Mr. Smith to describe
himself on record. As this happened,
Smith returned to a describable state,
curled up in a fetal position on the floor.
There was no sign of the restraints or the
chair in which Smith had been placed.
Subsequent tests showed similar results,
with minor variations in timing. Just by
being in physical contact with Mr. Smith,
the chair and restraints had
literally faded out of existence.
Evidence was really pointing towards
Mr. Smith’s anomalous effects being
potentially detrimental to the
people and objects around him,
but the experiments continued. They had to know
more before there was nothing left to know.
The next series of experiments
were performed with D-Classes,
and led Dr. Thorn and his team of researchers
to a number of frightening conclusions.
Two D-Classes locked in with
Mr. Smith as he slipped out of
existence began experiencing extreme
states of terror and distress.
Even when they could no longer see him, they could
still feel the presence of an entity in the room.
When the two D-Classes tried to escape, one of
them was almost mistaken for Mr. Smith himself:
He too was now starting to slip out of existence.
Both D-Classes were summarily terminated,
and Dr. Thorn began to wonder whether Mr.
Smith’s condition was contagious or if he was
instead somehow able to “lash out” at others
in his vicinity in a more localized fashion.
Only two other experiments were ever
performed on Mr. Smith before further
experimentation into his case was
permanently suspended. In the first,
a non-violent D-Class was placed in Mr.
Smith’s cell and ordered to ignore him.
Mr. Smith didn’t take this well - he began
attacking the D-Class, who fought back, breaking
Mr. Smith’s nose. Ironically, this physical
attack was actually beneficial to Mr. Smith,
as the violence helped ground him in reality and
secured his existence just that little bit more.
In the final experiment, Mr. Smith was given a
cell mate: A female D-Class who was allowed to
acknowledge him. The two appeared to become close,
and their time helped stave off Mr. Smith’s fading
just a little bit longer. It’s unknown if she
contracted his fading condition or somehow was
able to escape, but one day while Mr. Smith
slept, she simply disappeared. Mr. Smith fell
into a state of almost catatonic silence. Soon
after, he began to speak again, only to repeat
“I don’t want to go” again and again and again.
Experiments concluded for good not long after.
Because of his delicate mental state, Mr.
Smith is allowed a visit from a therapist
every week, and before any future
experiments are performed on Mr. Smith,
Researchers are required to seek
permission from his active therapist.
Because of his effects on the
minds of people aware of him,
Foundation protocol is to terminate Mr. Smith
immediately if he ever breaches containment. The
Site Director has also appended a memo to Smith’s
file - instructing personnel to refer to Mr. Smith
as SCP-1467 whenever he’s out of earshot. Doing
otherwise will incur severe punishments. Records
on Mr. Smith are backed up in six separate copies
and stored in different locations, in the hopes
that this will prevent the information
from decaying like Mr. Smith’s existence.
Mr. Smith’s story is one of pain, tragedy,
and existential horror. There’s no shortage
of SCPs that can cause XK-Class End
of the World Scenarios, but sometimes,
the terror of these anomalies pales
in comparison to SCPs that can bring
one person’s world crashing down around them.
According to all the SCP Foundation’s studies,
it’s likely that Mr. Smith will disappear some
time soon, regardless of their intervention.
Now check out “SCP-096 - Look at a picture of the
Shy Guy in Space? Shy Guy Questions and Theories”
and “SCP-5031 - Yet Another Murder Monster”
for more SCP Foundation mysteries explored!